following in the style of guardians of
the galaxy that is taking something that
seems totally ridiculous and making it
awesome somehow we have Ant Man again a
seemingly stupid idea that anyone with
half a brain would say would never sell
but you put some talented people some
great effects some creative ideas and
you get a really fun superhero Paul Rudd
plays an ex-con who's just been let out
of prison he wants to be let back in in
his daughter's life but mother sees him
as exactly what is an ex-con he tries to
take the route of getting an honest job
and standing upright but his background
is sadly not giving him enough credit so
through the help of his friends he tries
to take on another con in order to get
his life back on track yeah you figure
out the logic in that but he gets caught
by a scientist played by Michael Douglas
who's frustrated that his company is
working on a weapon that he thought he
got rid of years ago a weapon that can
shrink people down but still give them
unbelievable strength afraid that this
technology has fallen into the wrong
hands
Douglas talks to Rudd about breaking in
and getting the weapon to destroy it
forever using what the weapon of course
a suit that shrinks him down but still
gives him unbelievable powers on top of
that he's also given a device that can
control ants as well
it's about as adorably silly as it
sounds with the help of Douglass's
daughter played by even Jolene Lily it's
a heist movie of both the largest and
smallest of caliber the reaction to this
movie when it came out was pretty much
the same everyone said it was good not
great but look good it's a movie that
we've seen a million times a heist film
all the superhero stuff but it's done
creatively and uniquely enough that
people seem to like it fine I think I
liked it a little bit more than everyone
else I agree with what they're saying
that this has been done a million times
and we see the superhero stuff all
around but I feel like there's more
effort that was put into these
characters then you see a lot of times
in these kind of stories this is a
really good cast
they help breathe new life into a lot of
these cliches that we've seen over and
over but they deliver it in their own
unique and likeable way even though I've
heard this story about how Douglass
doesn't want to lose his daughter and
how Paul Rudd realizes that family is
the most important and all this stuff
something about the
way they say it in the way they do it it
feels like you're hearing it for the
first time I really appreciate actors
that can pull that off but on top of
that they take advantage of this
situation they make it fun they make it
visually interesting and you really feel
the size of this person the idea of
being shrunken down has been done a
million times and honestly when I heard
they were making a movie out of this I
was thinking oh god another Honey I
Shrunk the kids this is so done to death
but again they add new elements on top
of it the fact that is a super suit the
fact that he can get bigger and smaller
whenever he wants the fact that they can
make anything they want bigger or
smaller they make keychains toys all
sorts of various things gigantic and
it's great it's wonderful to see the
climax actually takes place onto Thomas
the Tank Engine Railroad set that's both
really funny and really action-packed at
the same time again it's taking kind of
a standard idea and it's adding a new
spin to it
I love how Marvel can do that it feels
like no matter what subject matter
they're doing or talking about they can
add something that's unique to it
whether it be a writer or a style of
acting or effects they always add that
element of cool so I like this movie
actually even more than most people like
it is it an action classic no and it's
no kind of masterpiece but I was
invested from beginning to end and I
want to know what's gonna happen in the
sequels
the idea of this guy joining the
Avengers sounds like a really good idea
I love to see how he interacts with
everybody he'll I want to see how all
these characters interact with the
Avengers
maybe that's how we judge a really good
movie that when it's done I don't want
to be done with it I want to see even
more with it I want to see more explored
I want to see more of these characters I
want to see more of their interactions I
want to see more things get bigger and
smaller I want to see more of those
creative action sequences so I
definitely had a lot of fun with it
shrink yourself down and experience it
for yourself
you